Виросла тут, так, народилась і виросла.
До закінчення школи [жила тут]. Відомо, що потім
всі десь роз'їжджаються в навчальні заклади.
Я, скажімо так, виїхала, виїхала ближче — в Житомир.
І не так часто сюди приїжджаю.
За походженням — я полька.
Переважно, якщо згадати, як мене батьки виховували,
то більше в польських традиціях.
Тобто дійсно як поляків виховували нас.
Добрий день. Що там? Як ваші справи?
— Добрий день!
— Фартушок, фартушок.
О, ви тюль купили, бачте.
І торт спекли!
— Збирались всі. Переважно рідня, було дуже багато…
— Велика родина була.
Збирались всі, частіше у моїх батьків.
Разом молилися, разом усе.
І говорили більше польською мовою.
Навіть на вулиці: віталися тільки польською мовою.
Ми ж там були маленькі, то все так само: вже щось розуміли.
Традиції, більше, мабуть, пов’язані з якимись святами, так?
Тобто, це, наприклад, Великдень чи Різдво.
Разом з родиною: діти, вже внуки ось.
І ось збираємося ми самі, пісні співаємо.
— На Різдво сіно під скатертиною обов’язково має бути.
— Так, як колись було.
— Ну що, будемо їсти?
— Так.
— Так, сідаємо.
— Сідайте.
Отче наш, що є на небесах!
Нехай святиться Ім'я Твоє.
Хай прийде Царство Твоє,
нехай буде воля Твоя
як на небі, так і на землі.
Хліб наш насущний дай нам сьогодні.
І прости нам провини наші,
як і ми прощаємо винуватцям нашим.
І не введи нас у спокусу,
але визволи нас від лукавого. Амінь.
У нас така велика родина,
і бабця любить всіх збирати за великим столом.
Насправді коли збираються всі разом
і слово дістається найстаршій, вона розповідає історії.
І мене дуже тішили завжди її історії про те,
як тут було на території під час Другої світової війни.
Знову ж таки, це не так тішило, як було цікаво,
а як тут люди жили, як спілкувалися, які були традиції.
Це все було настільки цікаво завернуто.
Я розумів, що в кожній такій родині є такі цікаві історії.
Виникла ідея записати спогади людей,
які безпосередньо тут проживають.
Поруч з Хмельницьким є таке поселення мазурів —
переселенців з Мазовії, польської Мазовії.
Це Гречани, мікрорайон Гречани,
є Шаровечка — це недалеко мікрорайон, та є Мацьківці.
Це три основні села, де збереглася мова.
Ви і зараз на вулиці можете зустріти людей,
які говорять такою старопольською мовою.
Їх поляки вже не розуміють.
Їх не розуміють ні українці, ні поляки.
Є така легенда, що чорт носив мазурів у мішку.
Була маленька дзюрка (дірка).
Де вони випадали, там вони і оселялись.
Але це така легенда. Насправді коли в 1700 році були набіги татарів,
фактично на цій території вже не було нікого.
Є така територія в Польщі називається Мазовія.
З тих земель багато хто отримав вольності тут —
вже переселялись цілими сім’ями,
для того, щоб тут обробляти землю,
мати можливість нормально жити.
Тому це триста років тому
люди переселилися сюди, утворили свої громади.
Тут, на цих територіях, продовжували жити,
продовжували спілкуватись своєю мовою, яка була там.
Найбільше поляків проживає на Житомирщині,
далі Хмельниччина.
На Львівщині як таких поляків, я думаю, більше.
У них акцент такий, бо вони вже близько до кордону.
Але, щоб така кількість поляків, там їх набагато менше,
ніж у Житомирській області чи Хмельницькій.
1925 року був створений документально,
а 1926 року офіційно — польський
Мархлевський район в Радянському Союзі.
Це перший польський район, взагалі який був.
Також відомо, що був створений німецький [район] —
це Полуники, тут недалеко, колись — Червоноармійськ.
І створювалися… Чому, скажімо, ці поселення національностей?
Щоб, як німців, тримати в одному осередку,
щоб можна було ними легко маніпулювати.
Так само було створено це польське поселення,
щоб тримати… Тут було найбільше скупчення поляків.
Щоб їх тримати, і в разі чого вміло ними маніпулювати.
Але… Протягом десяти років офіційно цей Мархлевський район проіснував.
Хоча я думаю, що перші пʼять років ніби був у розквіті,
бо давали дійсно там полякам:
відкриття шкіл, бібліотеки; давали переваги полякам,
що вони могли входити в управлінські ради.
Але наступні вже пʼять років, вже вони потроху починали…
Бачили, що поляки все одно не даються,
щоб ними маніпулювали,
що не до кінця вони поділяють політику
Радянського Союзу, яка на той час була.
І наступні пʼять років вони були менш такими процвітаючими,
але кінець кінцем був ліквідований цей Мархлевський район.
Позаяк ліквідований, то потрібно було щось із цими поляками зробити,
тобто їх покарати за те, що вони були непокірні,
що не вдалося впровадити Радянському Союзу свою ідеологію,
яку вони хотіли, тобто їм це не вдалося зробити.
Відповідно, 1935-1936 роки — це роки, коли масово поляків
з Мархлевська чи з околиць села — виселяли, вивозили в Казахстан.
Власне у Великий Луг, де залізниця, — і звідти їх масово виселяли…
Виїжджали вони родинами.
Наступні роки, кого з різних причин не довезли,
то відомо, що 1936-1937 роки —
це також роки, коли масово поляків розстрілювали.
Я історією своєї родини почав цікавитись, коли запитав
у свого дідуся, як, наприклад, звати його бабцю.
Дідусь мені, і це п’ятнадцять років тому,
він мені абсолютно нічого мені не розповів.
Тому що страх його, уявіть, незалежна Україна, 2000 роки,
і він не хоче мені назвати ім’я своєї мами,
хоча я знаю, що в архіві справи зараз відкриті.
Я зрозумів, що в людей насправді є страх за те,
що вони являються поляками.
Мені захотілося це дослідити, дослідити інші родини.
Два роки тому ми встановили,
де поховані батьки бабусі і дідуся,
де їх вивезли, за що їх розстріляли,
які були це фіктивні справи.
Для нашої родини це було як відкриття.
От Мазурик Людвик Іванович — це бабусине.
По діду другому є Пірог прізвище.
От маємо Пірох Людвіх — це він є.
Ну і по іншому діду прізвище Гурницький — десь нагорі.
У мене з діда, пра-пра-прадіда. І це все, ми всі поляки.
[польською] Я є поляк.
— [польською] Хто ти є?
— [польською] Я поляк.
— [польською] Евелінко, хто ти є?
— [польською] Полька мала.
— [польською] Який знак твій?
— [польською] Орел білий.
[польською] Де живеш ти? Поміж своїх.
В якій країні? На польській землі. (патріотичний дитячий вірш)
[сміються]
Загалом на щодень в родині тут — то українська.
В костелі, звичайно, там літургія — польська, українська.
В принципі, вже в нашій родині із малою,
то в нас іде трошечки вже така мішанка.
— І польська, і українська мови.
— Більше польська мова навіть.
Це [польською] молитовник.
Звичайно, що зараз батьки не моляться з нього,
бо його трошки страшно в руках тримати.
Бо це… йому вже років.
Але це те, що, на сьогодні вже більш нові у батьків є
— чи українською, чи польською мовою молитви, так?
Там від «Отче наш» до всіх інших молитов.
Але це ще, значить, моєї бабці Петрунелі.
Це й він. А тоді вже тато собі…
— А це чий? То тут дати немає.
— Це мама!
— Це мама...
— Так, це мама.
Ця польськість, ця потреба далі працювати
над підтриманням культури польської,
я думаю, що це передалося мені від батьків.
І в молодших класах я не пам'ятаю, щоб була польська мова,
крім того, що це в костелі вивчення,
також ми там вчили польську мову, катехизи були.
Але вже пізніше, мабуть, клас сьомий-восьмий,
вже почали приїздити до нас вчителі з Польщі,
які факультативно викладали польську мову.
У цій книжці ми вибирали маленькі й яскраві шматочки,
які б характеризували той або інший період.
Маємо тут дуже цікавий такий лист.
Це Мазури під час Другої світової війни.
У школі вчили писати кирилицею,
але людина розмовляє польською,
і слова, які вони польською [говорять],
вона кирилицею пише.
Переді мною стояв мій Андрій —
син і [я ставив собі питання]: «Чи буде йому це цікаво?».
Ну мені цікава ця історія, але «Чи буде йому це цікаво?».
Це, наприклад, одна з традицій, яку так само
хочемо продовжити в проєкті, називається «Три королі».
Це шостого січня ходили такі ряжені — Турок, Ангели.
Тобто така це сценка, яка залишилася в такому стані,
в якому вона була.
Цього року ми вже слова відновили, записали ті всі, що є.
І маємо такі, не знаю, чи вдасться, відновити
й відшити ці костюми по цих фотографіях.
Ця етнічна громада завжди мріяла про свій будинок,
і коли настав так званий період «коренізації»,
їм дозволили побудувати свій етнічний будинок,
де була б своя освітня, культурна програма
і дозвілля відбувалась.
До речі, цей будинок побудований добровільно:
мешканці з кожного подвір’я здавали про п’ять карбованців,
працювали над цим добровільно і вибудували будинок.
Зробили надпис про те, що це народний дім.
Я б сказав, що це відповідник громадському простору,
де люди збираються, і формуються.
Ту саму функцію він виконував, починаючи з 1928 року
і до 1937 року, тут, безпосередньо, в мікрорайоні.
В 1937 році, оскільки тут була
шістдесятикілометрова зона до Збруча,
є наказ Єжова про те, що треба зачистити територію
від абсолютно неблагонадійних елементів, до яких віднесли і поляків.
До 1937 року тут жила завжди вчителька,
тут відбувались заняття.
1937 року радянська влада забрала собі цей будинок,
тут почала діяти школа,
почала ДЮСШ торгово-промислова палата,
відтоді  його використовували абсолютно у своїх цілях.
Маючи трьох репресованих прадідів, які його будували,
мені здалося не зовсім правильно залишити цей будинок,
цю історичну спадщину без того, щоб сюди не долучатись.
Тому разом із громадськими активістами,
відгукнулось комунальне підприємство, яке захотіло взяти
на себе витрати по оформленню земельної ділянки,
оформленню самої будівлі,
зробити це офіційно настільки, для того,
створити громадський простір на шістдесят квадратів.
Планується такий невеличкий амфітеатр для
проведення заходів, для спілкування, для мам з дітьми.
Що стосується центру, то є потреба у класах:
класи мовні, інноваційні, технологічні.
Є потреба в невеличкій кав’ярні,
щоб поспілкуватись, почекати дітей.
Також це такий транзитний момент, якщо ти кудись їдеш,
когось чекаєш, в цьому мікрорайоні цього не вистачає.
З дитинства, з маленьких років,
це я, мабуть, мала чотири роки, чотири-пʼять років.
Я памʼятаю ці походи в костел.
Спочатку в каплицю, а потім в костел з батьками.
Бо костел для поляків...
Якщо говоримо взагалі за поляків,
то переважно це [польською] Бог, честь і Вітчизна.
Тобто це три основні такі постулати їхньої ідентичності.
Тобто — Бог, відомо це означає «костел».
І це те, що забрали у поляків.
Бо Радянський Союз заборонив, позакривав, так.
З костела зазвичай робили або якусь конюшню,
або якийсь там склад для тракторів.
Коли тільки відроджувався католицизм тут у Довбуші,
то священники були з Польщі.
— [польською] Чекаємо на Вас.
— [польською] Та невже?
— [польською] Нарешті познайомимось.
— [польською] Так.
В Україні я служив в Одесі, потім був Київ, був Житомир,
потім тут є недалеко від Довбуша село Кам’яний Брід.
З Кам’яного Броду повернувся в Польщу на 11 років
і рік тому вернувся сюди.
Раніше, тут ще за радянських часів
невеличка капличка була, тут поруч з нами.
Натомість як вже Радянський Союз перестав існувати,
то почалася нормальна праця і життя людей.
Зрозуміло, що хочуть тут молитись,
бо переважно жителі Довбиша — це католики.
Це був 1994 рік.
Я приїжджаю, а тут ані слова українською.
Хоча проповіді були українською, священник говорив українською.
Але переважно це була польська.
Приїжджаю в Україну, а тут всі польською мовою моляться.
Тепер таки державною мовою
в католицькій церкві в Україні — українською.
Тоже бачу, що так змінилось,
і духовенство більше з України, ніж з Польщі.
Ми вже розмовляємо більше українською, ніж польською.
А потім усвідомлення, що приїжджаю до країни,
де вже п’ять років триває війна.
Я пам’ятаю, в Польщу поїхав,
до людей говорив проповідь і кажу:
«Знаєте, я ніколи не думав, що буду стояти тут і
говорити, що приїжджаю з країни, де триває війна».
Гречани — мазурське село. І це з дитинства так,
не було навіть такого особливого моменту.
У мене українське громадянство, я громадянин України,
вважаю себе українцем з польським походженням.
Насправді це така тонка річ, де ми і українці, і поляки.